welcome to the 2015 East Westfall Pro
edition of all the all-star games in
professional sports
this one is sure to be the most
extravagant that's right these players
were selected by the fans too and when
it comes to flair these characters are
the creme de la creme
creme de la creme Vanderbilt University
Carswell Shumway Clemson haha Glen Dix
University of Alabama Dora Kahana hue
Marshall Lagoon Dupree West Virginia
University leaves a useable University
of Central Florida whisper [ __ ] Don's
always seen Central Connecticut State
University
gurgi peep Georgia Southern University
yeah
the burger shop Ferguson the University
of Virginia
universe the cell count along still take
me robo click Grambling State
Cornelius tank Carradine Florida State
University vogue Onias thicket suede
Duke momma tune shazbot Tulane
University swordless mime town
Jacksonville State University there's a
lot of talent in this game Eric let me
tell you something when you look at
players like Marmaduke shazbot ha ha
Clinton Dix and strong plug it you're
looking at players who made an impact
this year
I mean it's ha ha Clinton Dix even real
this guy was amazing so solid all season
long for the Green Bay Packers and when
you throw in guys like Lagoon Dupree
Fort Lee's mime town and D'Brickashaw
Ferguson this is surely gonna be a squad
for the ages I agree
now let's meet the players from the West
Prince Amukamara University of Nebraska
jr. jr. jr. jr. Texas Christian
University photos University of Oregon
Fozzy Whittaker the University of Texas
myriad profiteroles Utah mmm
Buster's Brown's Illinois speed cookie
your daddy famous hands man you know
horses you know wash that time it's full
kitchen Kent State University take it to
the limit college of the canyons
snarf men's plots East Los Angeles
College frosty record University of
Southern California Northwestern
University triple parity two ball stage
log jammer the baggage cling North Texas
University hey Ron
Rogers Cal
you
you